So let's talk about
kinetic energy again.
Remember, when we have an
object moving with speed v,
we define the kinetic
energy of the object
as a scalar quantity
1/2 mv squared.
This is scalar.
And what's very
important to realize,
it is reference frame
dependent because the velocity
of the object depends on what
reference frame we're in.
One thing to keep in mind
is remember our definition
of scalar product, a dot
b is the magnitude of a,
the magnitude of v, times
the cosine of theta.
So a vector dotted
into itself is just
the magnitude of
a squared, which
we can just write as a square
because the angle is zero.
So here, we have a v squared.
So the dot product
b dot b v squared,
enables us to write
kinetic energy
as 1/2 m v dot v. And we see
our first example of the scalar
product describing
a physical quantity.
If we had a coordinate
system where
we wrote v as vx i-hat plus
vy j-hat plus vz k-hat,
and we took the dot product
of that vector with itself,
then we just know that it's
the square of the components.
And so, in a
Cartesian system, we
can now say that
the kinetic energy
is 1/2 m vx squared plus
vy squared plus vz squared
because that's the
velocity squared.
So there's a simple way
to express, abstractly,
the kinetic energy
as a dot product
and explicitly in
a coordinate system
as the sum of the squares of
the components of the velocity.